oh
[Music]
joining me now is the journalist you
just saw alexa lavois alexa thank you
very much for joining us tonight
what did we just see in that video
uh first of all thank you for receiving
me on your show
uh what we saw um it's uh i'm here since
the beginning of the freedom convoy
since the 28th of january i report on
the ground every day
and
i wanted to be on the front line to see
the interaction between the police
officer and the protester because it's
all always there
that all the action
is on and as well i wanted to see
um if you have any violence coming from
all the protesters or
the police
and so i was there reporting on my
microphone my
revenues uh
leech on my neck
and um
so when the first shot of the gas tear
gun i was shot
i screamed because i was in shock i was
like okay something just happened
and it started to
be a little bit difficult to breathe and
afterwards the police officer went
towards the protester and they hit me
three times with the wood stick
and afterwards
i saw
it
everything go so fast but someone shot
me in my left legs with the
tear gas gone
uh it was point blank it was really next
to my legs and so i fell in the ground
because not only my legs was hurting but
all the gas from the canister went all
over me in my
eyes and in my mouth
so yeah alexa we reached out to the
ottawa police for a statement and they
pointed us toward an exchange with rebel
news watch
can you kindly explain how it was that
my colleague to my right here alexa
lavoie was shot point blank with a tear
gas canister
doing some very painful damage to her
what was the reason for that so i'm
unfamiliar with the incident you're
speaking of the vast majority of our
members have been extremely professional
alexa he said that look we asked people
to move very patiently over a course of
many days we had to clear the area
and
he said this is you know follow up on
these individuals who've been surveilled
and watched is going to continue for as
you heard in the angle an unlimited
amount of time i mean they're they're
going after everybody who was out there
and who didn't clear out
but
right now it's clear out but yeah we are
still in red zone so we have checkpoint
everywhere in the city stopping every
people in the street telling them show
you show me my your citizenship from
ottawa or you prove that you work here
or you will be arrested so right now
um my hotel is on the perimeter of
the um red zone so um
same up with my press card and they say
that i made up my card so i'm not really
allowed to work freely in the perimeter
so all the shop right now is closed so
they move the convoy for restarting the
economy and restarting the shop but
right now it's worse than when the
convoy was there
wow
alexa what is this really about let's i
know for the truckers it's about
mandates freedom and it became kind of
an anti-trudeau
especially the way things have been
handled the last few years movement a
broad-based movement not just a
vaccine movement this is a broad-based
movement
is he just at this point using this as
an excuse to crush dissent in the
country
i would say if follow is narrative you
don't you don't want to
try to understand the point of view of
other
canadians who
have suffered and still suffer from the
lockdown and from the mandate
that
these people is suffering right now so
why it doesn't take
a minute to try to communicate with the
people who have another narrative who
try to communicate who try to find a way
to reach
the middle to make everybody happy yeah
compromise yeah a little compromise or a
little maybe a little understanding
maybe have a meeting with some of the
organizers that probably would have
diffused a lot um
alexa i'm glad you're okay
you really took you took some shots and
um we're going to be following this very
closely but thank you very much for
joining us hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else